Aaron I don't remember all right we're
here right back and dance but it's time
why did he shoot oh it's a dinosaur he
shot the dinosaur hey then bruh such a
such a short all right what's going on
hold it hey whoa stop don't shoot I'm
not here to fight alright it doesn't
look like is there a fine asian I'm in
town on vacation
alright thank God another human being
[ __ ] love the music in this game I'm
dr. Michael Kaufman I work at this
hospital so maybe you can tell me what's
going on I really can't say no sure I
was taking a nap in the staff room when
I woke up it was like this holy [ __ ]
everyone seems to have disappeared it
does doesn't it
and it's snowing out this time of year
that's weird isn't a something's gone
seriously wrong I agree with you did you
see those monsters
now have you ever seen such aberrations
yes
there hasn't heard of such things yeah
when I both their momma creatures like
that don't exist okay
have you seen a little girl anywhere
looking for my daughter she's only seven
short black hair she's missing I'm sorry
but with all those monsters around I
highly doubt the cheese hey don't say
that son of a [ __ ] sorry I didn't mean
to alarm you well [ __ ] you your wife
she's here with you why do you care
she died four years ago yeah it's just
me and my daughter I see I'm sorry I
wonder if we'll I'd better be going
should I do whatever I can't just sit
around here doing nothing
are you implying that I'm not doing
anything good luck out there so long
[ __ ] alrighty then um the thing is
that I pick up the map or not I don't
have a map of this place
all right we need to get back then
because I think the map is in the
reception no well maybe we don't get the
map yet
that's weird anyway uh we're gonna go
through here anyway
I know there's a lot of walking in this
game but that's that's how it acts and I
like it I love this game um I'll be
brothers are enjoying it as well maybe
we can find a map here Oh are we
somebody doors and nomads well that's
jam what about this one
that is jammed are they all gonna be Jam
nope then I see boobs there in the
corner here's a map all right cool
basement map girl I'm not going to no
basement
hospital basement Bao don't think I
don't see you over there which stored I
come from hey blue okay I'll be taking
that thank you very much
you probably hide it there oh it's a
basement King all right
that's I'm definitely thinking we'll go
to the basement now
ah [ __ ] this game is so creepy even
though yeah it's totally see boobs over
there give me boobs
you are nice pixelated boobs ah kitchen
yeah a health drink in the kitchen
because why not
uh water bottles a plastic bottle
alright I don't know what I need you for
but I'll be taking it not more boobs I'm
just gonna assume every pixel i sees
boobs that doesn't make sense
boobs ever okay uh what do we got in
here
well someone's been reading this place
wha-what is this a glass vial ice
shatter what is that what is that
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I bet yep yeah oh I
don't want to go here uh really nope
nope why not go in there are you kidding
me oh [ __ ] what is that um he's not
working oh you [ __ ] cockroaches how
do i all right oh hey Chi Lam ah they're
[ __ ] everywhere alright [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] BAM
next one by four Oh brah Oh brah all
right my health is okay next one
BAM oppressed pudding oh [ __ ] stop
running away kick it but you're doing it
wrong all right all right all right
there we go splat ah splat Explo oh
that's right all right Pepe is doing his
job at least every [ __ ] door is long
what about this one of course what an
elevator the elevator doesn't appear to
be working with son of a [ __ ] then I
check all the doors what is this okay in
the house generator power Li I see you
operating room store alright so that
pretty nicely I think my why does the
elevator sound like the creepiest thing
ever
ah elevator elevator elevator elevator
oh I have to click ok and now we've been
there let's go to number 2
hello
Early's about this time this Jam what
the [ __ ] is wrong with this floor then I
guess I go back I guess I go back I
guess I go back and check out the third
floor baby girl all right
why do we got the same my god boobies at
least well that was a [ __ ] waste of
time once when the ambience well I don't
like this alright I guess we'll [ __ ]
go back and save her something I don't
[ __ ] know
are they mind [ __ ] me again I think
they're mind [ __ ] me again out they a
pretty [ __ ] sure there was no fourth
floor it says fourth floor up there
though oh this is gonna be terrible huh
huh hey I know that place I ran there
when I was being lost in the city it's I
need a key to go there though so I guess
we got to find the key somewhere I've
shed oh [ __ ] me
pip I does not approve of this situation
watch
son of a [ __ ] lock the door all right
pity don't worry you got this this run
like a [ __ ] right like a [ __ ] that's
my mom all the same run and ignore it
oh come on aah Oh God
oh this is bad this is bad rez
this is terrible huh that's fine like
it's this big bin
I'm not gonna die not gonna be enemies
I'm sure there will be a nice mine there
and it will help me on the way back [ __ ]
[ __ ] this I'm out of here all right
yeah yap yap yap yap-yap EMP mu mu P mu
P haha I can't do anything in here haha
I can't click anything I'm stuck in here
what I'm okay because I don't have my
flashlight okay well let's go to bed
this is [ __ ] the school all over
again hello hello ah goddamnit the aim
bans answers ha panic
hi mr. Schey what's going on here man
you had trap here forever Eddie don't
say that mr. are they gonna mind [ __ ] me
again I already got in wine [ __ ] ones
that's enough what do we got on the
third floor then come on that's not nice
alright okay plan plan dos we go to the
base floor and we try to save because I
don't want to die right now this is
gonna be bad it's gonna be monsters
how do we kill it how do we kill it
Bucky Oh Bam Bam Bam Bam
don't stop me I'll shoot you and your
[ __ ] tits are you dead
another one isn't it
hello that's not help doing I just go in
here
Bam Bam Bam shoot you no no this is
terrible
alright I gotta go I got a [ __ ]
pyramid man what am I supposed to do
with it alright for what some [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay I waste it all ma'am oh come
on alright I'm taking this I don't feel
like checking this out well don't do it
it's nice I'm glad I wasted all my
shotgun ammo for some [ __ ] hell
I should have just [ __ ] ran for I'm
sorry alright I'm not a Silent Hill
expert what do you want I'm not gonna
have sex with you is that the accent
then where does this go huh oh cars hot
outside
alright slower [ __ ] to the left
to the right by the [ __ ] am I
um or no no no no how that hurts I have
feelings too you know
okay I'm gonna die in here I gotta die
in here
ah ha ha there's a sound beyond the door
hey shut up alright good
I'm glad we got that cleared now what
look at my health I can't catch a cat no
more ha ha ha this is the [ __ ] window
what is up with this place bacon bacon
what the hell is something at the window
I wish I had a map at least parrot it at
her map you mess it well I don't need
maps I guess it was nothing that's nice
alright what I got in here what is this
lovely alright
mo at least I'll take that nothing helps
really doesn't help anything huh alright
[ __ ] you over in the kitchen now hey you
want to cook some with me let's use
creepy on him
maybe it's effective hey brown let's
make him come over here or not
hi there how you [ __ ] do it you want
to taste them up ese it's a preview you
can't kill me
why don't you die be serious
they take a lot whoa what is he doing oh
stop that
that's right it just came I think it
came all right it's a health care at
least yeah I'll take that thank you very
much all right Prez I can end this
episode here I can favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe become a brush today
and I'll see you next episode about a
man mean yeah the booty
come on she said we're gonna talk in
Russia Sirius Black is died are you on
drugs
yes hahaha good this explains everything